(slow piano music)
- I had thought about adopting
since I was a teenager,
and I remember thinking no
child should ever grow up
in an orphanage.
The difference between
growing up with a family
versus growing up without
a family changes the course
of a human beings life.
(slow piano music)
- To become adoptive parents
there's a major process
of interviews, of background checks,
of making sure your home
is safe for your children.
(slow piano music)
- I remember a social worker saying to me,
"Look, we want these
kids to have families,
"and we're trying to opt
you in, not opt you out."
It's not that they're looking
for people with perfect lives.
They're looking for
people who are committed
to helping a child.
(soft acoustic music)
- The first thing we did
when we went down there was
essentially see if this would
be the sort of place we would
want to adopt from.
As we got to know the director,
she introduced us to this
little boy named Kembe,
and said "I think I know
who you guys need to meet."
I distinctly remember it was nap time,
and so we walked around the
corner into his bedroom,
and he was laying in his crib,
and he's laying on his back wide awake,
this little guy, huge smile on his face,
I kid you not, just this
beaming smile on his face,
and just kind of quiet,
and looking up at us.
Just beaming this sense of baby joy.
We're like, "What kid exudes
this kind of positive energy?"
She like, "This is your little guy."
We're like, "Oh my God,
you're right, this is.
"This is our son."
- When you birth a child,
you meet the child that day,
and it's this beautiful
moment, and then you go home,
and you have the child with you.
But in this case we we meet the child,
and it's beautiful, and we're
excited, and then we go home,
and he still lives somewhere else.
That was really difficult, and you know,
then we go home, and we just
continue submitting paperwork.
We had to go down for a
visits sometimes just to sign
things in a courthouse.
I was really just down
there for a casual visit.
I was checking on paperwork,
getting to hang out
with Kembe a little bit,
and the earthquake happened.
It was insane.
It was like being on blanket
that someone was trying
to shake off.
We survived, we were all okay.
Many people in the country
did not fare as well.
It was a really devastating
day for their country.
He, and the other orphans
were literally sleeping
on the ground of a driveway
was the most difficult
aspect of that adoption.
We weren't really sure what
was gonna happen to him.
would happen with the adoption.
(bright acoustic music)
I really became dedicated
to trying to get our son,
and all of the kids that
were in the same situation
home to their families
because there were hundreds
of children in the same scenario
who had adoptions approved,
and were literally just waiting
on a signature to be able to
come home to their families.
I started working with some
of our state representatives,
and advocating with them,
and with the Haitian
government to figure out a plan
to grant humanitarian
parole to these kids,
the ones who were already matched,
the ones whose paperwork
was just waiting for
someone to approve it.
A week later, through a
partnership with the US government,
and the Haitian government,
they did grant humanitarian parole,
and refugee status for those children.
- It was actually a bill in
congress that was passed called
Help for Haiti,
and it granted humanitarian
parole for, I believe,
800 children who were in
situations like our son.
- Kembe popped onto a military
jet with the other orphans,
and flown to the US without us.
- I was on the airplane to Orlando,
found out that he was there
at a different airport.
So, somehow, got over
to the other airport.
Finally at one in the
morning, two in the morning,
they start bringing one
or two kids out at a time.
At this point it's been three
years since I first met Kembe.
Eventually, somebody sees him coming,
and says, "Mark, Kembe's coming out!"
So, I ran over to this little gate area,
and the officer who carried
him out hands him to me,
and Kembe just melts in my arms.
He's exhausted, emotionally
exhausted, physically exhausted.
I'm physically and emotionally exhausted,
and I just want to
embrace him, and hold him.
After all these years,
and after all this
trauma of the earthquake,
I was just so thankful that he was there.
The officer gave me this paper, and said,
"Hang in there, congratulations."
It was very affirming, and wonderful,
and took the visa, and held my son,
and just didn't want to let him go,
and just held him for so long.
- Kembe had three siblings
at home that had been
waiting for years for him to come home.
We got balloons, and we got signs,
and we had lots of family
and friends who had
been waiting as well.
Finally, you know, we see
Mark and Kembe coming out,
and the kids just ran and hugged him,
and we were all so excited
to finally be together
as a family.
(soft acoustic music)